[Music]
there's no question that london is the
dirty money capital of the world
the uk didn't just turn a blind eye to
russian money we welcomed it
for many decades now london has been
rolling out the red carpet to corrupt
and criminal individuals from around the
world britain is a very open financial
hub
it's really important you have really
clear well-enforced rules and that's
something britain simply doesn't have
there are key aspects of our legal and
financial system that makes the city of
london a great place to bring dirty
money and launder wealth the russians
have accounted for about a billion
pounds worth of residential property in
london
we have now woken up
dirty money's being seen for what it is
which is a poison to democracy it's
taken
the real slipping of putin's mask
an act of aggression
so appalling
the uk appears to have completely lost
its moral compass
this is really a tale of two empires
the british empire and the soviet empire
and the british empire as it unraveled
retained lots of outposts british virgin
islands channel islands they needed a
new purpose and the purpose they found
was as providers of financial secrecy of
shell companies corporate camouflage
ways for people to move through the
globalizing economy without leaving
their fingerprints on anything the
engine of the multi-trillion
dollar offshore industry
rife with dirty money
this is how
corruption went global while the british
empire was doing that soviet empire was
collapsing too
greatest act of corruption the world has
probably ever seen the scramble in a few
years in the 90s to grab the wealth of
the entire soviet empire create this
oligarchy
that went then surging out into the
world and where this all meets is london
the place where dirty money comes to
party
the origins came with the big bang under
margaret thatcher when she
started liberalizing the financial
services sector
you bookmark client i will sell you half
a million at 673 and then that carried
on under the labour government with a
mission on deregulation david cameron i
think got it thank you very much
after he left office
people have simply refused to take on
the challenge to eradicate dirty money
from london over the past two decades
the uk has really welcomed in russian
money of all kinds
law firms real estate agents the
government there are
statements on the record from boris
johnson our prime minister from when he
was the mayor of london saying that he
wanted to make
london a hub for russian money the stock
exchange welcomed lots of russian
companies wanted them to make the uk and
london
their european base
one of the reasons why britain has got
into this hole is that britain's ruling
elites believe that you should get out
of the way of businesses at all costs so
if you're a senior civil servant
what you need to demonstrate to
ministers is that you won't cause
trouble for business we see it all the
time in things like failures of
financial regulation before the
financial crisis failures are building
regulation they've been exposed by the
grenfell tower fire the golden visa
schemes were introduced in 2008
[Music]
the golden visas were introduced by the
labour government to attract wealth and
capital into london if you had enough
money you could buy citizenship in
theory there were checks on this but in
practice they didn't work of course it
was abused by oligarchs and kleptocrats
who wanted to bring their dirty money
into london
and use the scheme to establish
legitimacy and credibility in what was
seen as a trusted jurisdiction it's
quite a remarkable idea that citizenship
is for sale at all it is a scandal that
i've been pursuing for many years and
i'm delighted the government has finally
abolished the scheme peaked in about
2012 when i think around 1200 golden
visas were issued that year 60
were actually for either russians or
chinese
[Music]
if you've seized power in kazakhstan
moscow venezuela wherever it may be you
are enriching yourself of the fat of the
land
you stick it in london and what comes
with it in london at this full
suite of services for
putting a legitimate face on yourself
let's say you wanted to bring dirty
money into the city of london and
integrate it into the system there are
basically four key stages placement
layering integration and defense so
let's start with bringing your money
from say a latvian bank account a cayman
bank account you want to then move that
into a uk shell company
it's possible to spend gigantic amounts
of money in the uk economy with a mascot
you're supposed to tell the company's
house registry who the real
owners the beneficial owners of
companies are but in practice it's
really easy to evade those rules and
fundamentally no one goes after
companies that just lies essentially a
wild west of information which is
unverified and in some cases ludicrous
you can put forward any name hide your
identity there are adolf hitler's and
donald ducks and mickey mouses it is so
easy to register a company on companies
house costs 12 pounds you can do it in
minutes and crucially no one checks the
information usually the applications are
approved within 24 hours they don't
actually have the statutory power
to check the information to investigate
false information or remove it from the
register now there are some addresses
within the uk that have
thousands of companies registered to
them and if you go and knock on the door
you won't find staff they are literally
being set up as a shell to hide the true
ownership of who really controls and
benefits from the money flowing through
that company this is a crucial area that
the government says it wants to tighten
up but this is one of those reforms
that's been talked about for years and
nothing has been done
[Music]
the next stage you want to layer to move
this money around in a series of
complicated financial transactions that
will distance you from the money and
from your source of wealth that's where
the uk banks come in
some 86 banks have been involved in
obtaining
moving
corrupt wealth around the world the cash
by the time we've got to london it's
probably already gone through a couple
of british overseas territories like the
british virgin islands
step three is you want to integrate your
wealth into the uk system you want to
buy assets including uk property
lawyers real estate agents are on hand
to help you do that
[Music]
once you've got the cash into london you
can then basically use it like it clean
people aren't bringing this money on
shore to like to put into drug gangs
right they're putting it on shore to buy
houses in kensington
the buying really started with mr
abramovic i was showing him various
properties which eventually bought one
in kensington in excess of 90 million
their fortunes were enormous
they were a target for state agents in
london have you got a russian type
conversation was going around the agency
typical russian buyer would be looking
for a substantial
home larger than most grade one grade
two listed
location would be belgravia mayfair
knightsbridge there wasn't that much
stock but when anything did come
available your thoughts will immediately
find one of these oligarchs who wanted
to buy one you can own uk property
through a shell company even an offshore
shell company and if you do own it
through an offshore shell company you
don't have to say who really owns that
property and lawyers are on hand to
advise on these complicated transactions
which creates an opaque ownership
structure of some of our most valuable
uk homes roughly 84 000 homes here in
the uk are owned anonymously we have
identified 6.7 billion pounds of uk
property that has been bought with
suspicious wealth
1.5 billion of that that's around 150
land titles has been purchased by
russian individuals who are either
accused of corruption or have close
links to the kremlin we found 830
million pounds worth of uk property
owned by russian individuals through
shell companies based in our crown
dependencies and overseas territories
and there's been about 10 to 20
important houses sold to oligarchs they
normally had a third party it could have
been a lawyer it could have been an
intermediary you didn't really have much
dialogue with the principal and a fleet
of cars would arrive and all blacked out
windows he subsequently realized there
were some very unpleasant situations
occurring with people
being murdered and falling out of
windows
the recent events in ukraine have
demonstrated that all one's earlier
thoughts suspicions are as bad as they
could ever possibly be if those buyers
invested money here was to launder it
then you wish you hadn't had anything to
do with it
finally you want to defend your wealth
and your reputation and the city of
london is the perfect place to come if
you want to do that our libel laws which
are very claimant friendly make the high
court a perfect place to bring your
blockbuster libel claims the city of
london is home to some of the top law
firms in the world who can help you
bring them when questions are asked
about polygox find investigative
journalists including those at the
financial times
the lawyers try to shut them up
i've had a bit of experience of doing
battle in the high courts with powerful
figures from the former soviet union
there's an entire industry based in
london the big heavy duty reputation
management law firms they harang the
press and broadcasters newspapers are
vastly outgunned there's often vexatious
cases that are brought solely to just
run up bills to delay things to cause
problems to make editors think oh god do
we need to do this so even when we try
to expose the wrongdoing the kleptocrats
use their resources
to close down the conversation and the
lawyers
make a lot of money but support the
oligarchs we were involved with one case
we were owed money
and we
wanted to settle it but they said no
we're not going to pay you so we had to
go to a court very large
individual
came to our door one day and made it
clear to us we should uh
drop the case a man had
quite a number of gold teeth and he was
built like a gorilla it was threatening
one of the attractions of being in
london is the network of
lawyers accountants oligarchs
kleptocrats do deals
english law provides a
stamp of legitimacy we've identified 81
law firms 86 uk banks
and surprisingly
177 uk education institutions that have
accepted or moved dirty money from
around the world russians own our
newspapers their children are in the
elite public schools their properties
are
in mayfair we have so one or two
properties where people are now on the
sanction list it does
make you think
am i doing the right thing look at the
house of lords and the number of
fortunes made in the soviet union either
by nationals from the former soviet
union or peers who rent out their
legitimacy to
highly questionable oligarchs to sit on
the boards of their companies look at
the political donors
who buy access to our most senior
elected officials from the prime
minister down i'm often asked
to address political representatives
from the commonwealth on how to ensure
proper accountability i now do it with
shame i feel phony not just because of
the way we've allowed dirty money to
come into the country
but because the way that dirty money has
infected the public domain and then
infected our politics go back to
the way we responded to the kovid
pandemic we talked about a chamocracy
meity contracts look at say lord lebedev
does it matter that he's the son of a
former kgb officer does it matter that
his fortune was earned in a place run on
kleptocratic rules does it matter that
tory donors have
roots in
the russian kleptocracy who will of
course insist that they are just
legitimate business people but the
source of their wealth isn't ultra
corrupt system they are connected at
every level we have city grandees lords
former ministers sitting on their boards
the integration of russian business
with
london's political and business elite is
complete you can buy a bit of university
and name a wing of an art gallery after
you and suddenly
you're either an entrepreneur or a
statesman as opposed to being a thief or
a despot
[Music]
britain is a very open financial heart
but always be vulnerable to dirty money
coming into the country and it's really
important in that situation that you
have really clear well-enforced rules
and that's something britain simply
doesn't have there have been huge
questions asked for years about the uk's
record on enforcement often uk law
enforcement agencies are simply
outgunned by the big lawyers that worked
for corrupt and criminal individuals the
serious four office for example has a
budget of 50 million pounds a year any
self-respecting oligarch makes that
amount of money in less than a week i
really hope that the uk government will
make sure the national crime agency the
serious fraud office and others have
teeth that can bite
we had to have a war to bring this all
to a head and it's a shame that so many
people have died as a consequence of it
the crisis in ukraine has marked
a real turning point we are waking up
now because a kleptocrat has sent troops
into a neighboring democracy to the fact
that this dirty money is a weapon the
kleptocrats are at war with democracy
there are a series of legislative
changes that have been talked about for
a really long time and the government
has delayed and fails to implement those
things over a really long period and
that's how we've got to where we are now
david cameron promised me in 2015-2016
that he would bring in a bill
enable us to have a public register of
the beneficial ownership of properties
that had been acquired through foreign
entities the economic crime belt that
the government has recently passed is
landmark legislation that brings forward
the long-promised hand-delayed property
register overseas companies that
purchase a uk property have to tell the
land registry who really owns and
controls those companies one hopes that
that is the beginning of the end of
people hiding behind offshore vehicles
everybody will have to account for
being the beneficial owner on anything
whether it's an airplane a a yacht or a
home the economic crime bill makes
sanctions easier to impose unexplained
wealth orders easier to pursue
unexplained wealth orders were a new
investigative tool given to law
enforcement agencies in 2018 it's a type
of court order that compels someone with
assets of over 50 000 pounds to explain
how they could afford them if it doesn't
seem to make sense there have only been
four cases where they've been
successfully used and the amount seized
is tiny part of the problem is the costs
of being unsuccessful and bringing them
the new economic crime bill basically
caps the amount of liability that police
forces can have if they're ordered to
pay costs we are going to get an
economic crime bill 2.0 in a few months
time i really hope that the next
economic crime bill really gets a handle
on some of the loopholes that still
remain
[Music]
kleptocracy spreads like a virus and it
starts to change how people treat power
with all this dirty money that's arrived
in the uk with all these fortunes made
in kleptocracies you've got to start to
wonder is our political system
becoming more corrupt as a result to
bring an end to london grads london
could become much less open we can take
serious steps to limit the capacity of
some
types of people to come here the
political consensus is around if you
like the second option which is keeping
london as this very open rules-based
place
but
uh by trying to introduce new rules into
the system to make it harder for people
who are really bad actors to disguise
their money the government's approach to
sanctions has been far too little
far too late it's a knee-jerk response
to a horrendous act of kleptocratic
aggression by
one of history's great kleptocrats
we have shown an amazing tolerance up to
this point to people we
consider to be
so plugged into putin's regime that if
we confiscate some of their wealth that
will make this man change course i first
raised the issue of abramovic over a
year ago
when the leader of the opposition in
russian navalny was imprisoned by
vladimir putin navalny said there that
if the west really wanted to support
democracy we ought to take action
by sanctioning putin's cronies around
him at the time the government took no
action it's important to remember that
this is a much bigger problem it may be
you know called london grad but actually
this is not just about russia and our
response seems to be
we want to try to pressure one
kleptocrat we need to dismantle our
complicity
in kleptocracy wherever it comes from
clamp down massively on secrecy in the
economy and provision of secrecy by
large parts of the former british empire
the uk is in a uniquely strong position
to crack down on kleptocrats because of
our position as the so-called capital of
money laundering fawning service
to this dirty money over all these years
has now ironically put us in the
position to land the biggest blow there
are going to be clear costs to the
measures that the uk has taken exodus of
businesses from russia we have also seen
from the professional services and law
firms that are based in the uk
announcements that they are going to
refuse to do any more work for russian
clients there will be a financial cost
to that dirty money has benefited
certain sectors in the uk there are
professionals who have benefited in
monetary terms from the dirty money
flowing through the uk from the services
we offer but there are many people in
the uk who have not
have been economically enriched what
sort of society do we want
i will believe it's the end of london
grad
when i see it
there is a huge gulf between talking
tough on things like sanctions dirty
money and economic crime and doing
something about it
the uk is guilty of laundering the
world's dirty money we help facilitate
global corruption we in the west decided
that we would march into russia bankers
consultants entrepreneurs lawyers
and remake this collapsing communist
empire in our own image
that we weren't remaking the former
soviet union in our image
the new kleptocratic order was remaking
us in their image
this dirty money is poisoning our
democratic institutions suborning
politicians to serve the interests of
this international tiny oligarchy it's
undermining the free press these are the
only things that separate us
from these authoritarian regimes these
institutions and this dirty money is
corroded
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you